samedi soir pierre palmade était
l'invité de laurent ruquier et
d'ailleurs c'est une des premières fois
de la saison clowe et passe le million
de téléspectateurs elle 1,1 million de
téléspectateurs
il était invité pour son autobiographie
mais aussi ses addictions pour évoquer
son lit mais aussi ses addictions à
l'alcool et à la drogue
pierre palmade je vous le dis je vais
toujours je n'ai jamais caché ici j'aime
énormément
voilà c'est vrai que j'aime beaucoup de
personnages j'aime beaucoup le comédien
je trouve que c'est un talent
exceptionnel il a évoqué plein de choses
chez laurent ok on vous fait une vidéo
récap les déclarations de pierre palmade
sur l'homosexualité
j'aime ou j'aime pas si vous n'avez pas
vu cet extrait c'était assez fort et
pierre si tu nous regardes vraiment je
t'aime fort et on t'embrasse regarde
quelques semaines après les fausses
accusations de viol dont il a été
victime pierre palmade a décidé de faire
la tournée des médias pour s'exprimer
sur ses addictions à la cocaïne à la
drogue mais aussi parlé de son
homosexualité invités d'on n'est pas
couché samedi soir dernier pierre
palmade s'est lancé dans une théorie sur
l'homosexualité qui a beaucoup fait
parler sur internet et qui a mis en
colère de nombreux téléspectateurs
selon lui il existerait deux types
d'hommes homosexuels les gays et les
homos et à les homos et les gays
schématiquement je me suis fait deux
schémas les gays c'est des gens qui
mangent des quirighetti vivre gays et
les homos ce sont des gens qui sont
homos mais c'est pas marqué sur leurs
fronts qui on le sait pas quand il parle
on ne sait pas quand steve hill ne on ne
le sait que quand on va dans leur
chambre à coucher
très vite ces propos ont révolté de
nombreux internautes qui ont fait
connaître leur mécontentement et ont
tenu à rappeler à l'humoriste que ses
propos allaient à l'encontre du combat
pour la tolérance de leur côté sos
homophobie et urgences homophobie ont
fait savoir qu'elles trouvaient les
propos de l'humoriste déplacés et vous
qu'en pensez vous alors que la polémique
est justifiée ou inappropriés à
guillaume mélanie mon pote guillaume 1
le coprésident d'urgence humeau phobique
longs mois ce qui est très souvent nous
voir
qui a dit non pierre il n'ya pas les
homos et léguer n'oublie jamais que
c'est grâce à ces guides qui mangent des
quirighetti vivier qu'aujourd'hui qui
osent enfin pleinement assumé homos
alors on dit merci à celles et ceux qui
se sont battus pour n'y aucun rapport et
directives j'aime j'aime pas alors
j'aime j'aime participer avec et
franquart et amène également un bal à 1
min remp à sadio jour d'hui qui est
l'ami de jean michel maire alors
mesdames vous
mais pas les propos de claire non ce
n'est pas la police mais pas la
polémique jean paul je n'aime pas la
polémique parce que je trouve qu'elle
n'a pas de sens en fait il a exprimé son
ressenti alors je peux comprendre que
certains aient mal compris et mal vécu
mais il n'a pas dit qu'il y avait des
airs archi dans les chais les
homosexuels qui auraient des homosexuels
plus valable que d'autres ce qu'il
voulait dire c'est que lui-même
d'ailleurs il en a fait un post facebook
par la suite pour ce pour expliquer si
peut-être ceux qui n'avaient pas compris
ses propos en gros il dit moi je vais de
l'un à l'autre je vais de deux buts de
l'omo qui est militant et qui exprime
son militantisme et avec raison parce
qu'il faut des couilles faut mener ce
combat et en même temps de l'autre côté
il ya des moments où je n'ai pas envie
de le revendiquer de mettre en porte
drapeau et c'est à mon avis ce qu'il a
voulu dire et et c'est pour ça que je
comprends pas vraiment cette polémique
même si voilà vous nettoie cette
polémique non je dors les associés sont
utiles mais je dis aussi aux assauts ce
ça m'agace quand tu les as as deviennent
extrême dans l'autre sens à dia ridicule
ce qu'il a voulu dire et pardon je lui
dis de la même manière qu'il a voulu
dire c'est qu'il ya des gens comme moi
donc je suis comme lui pardon je vais le
dire je n'aime pas ça à moi qu'ils sont
homosexuels dans la sexualité on préfère
coucher des garçons mais dans la vraie
vie c'est vrai que pardon jeu dans la
vraie vie je ne tiens pas la mana garçon
je n'ai pas les goûts des autres
homosexuels j'aime la viande machin même
ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est que avoir un
mais on n'exigeait pas la main d'un
garçon n'y a rien de mal et pas de mal
je me sors c'est vrai que je ne me sens
pas très à l'aise avec le le le couple
le couple aux hommes je reconnais ça
c'est peut-être pour ça aussi que je
célibataire j'ai plus de mal avec ça je
vis une sexualité homosexuelle
et si vous ne pouvez pas justement un
mathieu juste après mais pas en vouloir
à ceux qui le trouvent nos longues non
voilà j'en veux pas mais quand quentin
guillaume mélanie dia qui se sont battus
avant et on accepte parfaitement mais ça
n'a aucun rapport le seul rapporte qu'il
soit battu avant c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
peut justement être homosexuel de
manière libre ça c'est grâce aux joueurs
nous abattrons nous plaindre revanche
que chacun vive sur l'homosexualité
comme il le veut sans que les assos vous
tombe dessus dès qu'on dit pas
exactement ce qu'elle pense parfois les
assauts sont trop extrêmes et si on
n'est pas comme eux eh ben on dit du mal
alors les assauts si je vous dis elles
ont tendance est extrêmement si oui il
faut qu'elle soit si long et si c'est
vrai le riad qui vivait il est si bien
qu'on veut autre chose si elle est passé
des choses après peuvent se dire voilà
on laisse passer un petit truc qui
truquent bien d'accord les samedis entre
le des cons je sache
d'accord avec vous à la hausse et nous
voilà en plus ils portent pas du tout
jugement sont légués pierre palmade idée
comment lui ce rosé la polémique nagel
les propos de pierre pas nos questions
je n'aime pas je n'aime pas cette
polémique je la trouve les pas de robert
dans l'avion non non non non vraiment
honnêtement et puis en plus il le dit
comme une leur sens on va pas juger à sa
place la façon de tourner le ressentir
il le dit comme il ne ressent il exprime
comme il ne ressent donc y'a même pas à
juger quoi que ce soit là dessus
jean-michel oui moi j'aime pas la
polémique et ont pu parce que longtemps
les homosexuels ne se sont pas tues le
le pouvoir le devoir ou la liberté de
pouvoir dire ce qu'ils pensaient pour
une fois qu'il ya maintenant qu'ils
osent s'exprimer
on peut pas leur tomber dessus quand ils
disent vraiment qu'est ce qu'ils ont au
fond d'eux voilà il explique comment il
le vit comment il vit sa sexualité et
son homosexualité je trouve ça bien
qu'ils n'ont pas le sens qu'on tombe
dessus maxime et denitsa l'année
dernière sur d'als y avait notre amis
humoristes bienveillance et jean pierre
blanchette jan fischer ancien cavalier
qui voulaient danser qu'un garçon et ça
avait été refusé par la production est
ce que vous seriez les couples voilà
fifi garçon garçon non sec et sa maxime
oui elle a après certaines danses un peu
difficile penser que pour techniquement
c'est plus compliqué médias régaler il
ya des danses comme le contemporain des
choses comme ça qui qui fonctionnerait
mais des valses et un peu moins est ce
qu'on pensait que ça peut être possible
dans danse avec les stars l'an prochain
j'avais fait à d'ailleurs un duo avec
bâti giabiconi d'accord il ya au
palladium homme mon papa de eog est
intacte ça marche très bien en fait
c'est du très beau deux hommes qui peut
danser ensemble je pense que pendant la
semaine du switch quand on change de
partenaire
la balle a en prime on peut le faire
défoncer